yeah I I knew I didn't know what
happened at the in the moment but I got
in the Huddle and everybody was telling
me and I was like I I got y'all but I'm
not coming out the game so we can figure
out on the sidelines I was hoping we
scored obviously we didn't end up
getting in the end zone but uh yeah it
was a first for me and who whose helmet
came in it was wasn't a backup that just
happened to be out they they have a
backup that's out there we got to talk
about where where we store the backup
cuz it was like frozen so like when I
tried to put it when I tried to put it
on it was completely Frozen I couldn't
get it on I don't know if anyone got a
picture of it it didn't look great um
but uh we able to adjust it on the
sideline get it kind of warmed up a
little bit um and uh get get rolling
from there